I'M HERE WITH MY PANEL.
THANK YOU, VERY MUCH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Larry: SUCH A GREAT CROWD
HERE TODAY.
NIGHTLY SHOW WRITER AND AS I WAS
TOLD ALLEGED COMEDIAN.
JORDAN CARLOS.
JORDAN CARLOS HERE TONIGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
COMEDIAN AND VERY FUNNY MAN
CHRISTIAN FINNEGAN IS HERE.
VERY FUNNY.
AND CNNs CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT AND HOST OF CNN
INTERNATIONAL AS "AMANPOUR"
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: SO, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE DENNIS HASTERT THING
EARLIER.
IT'S INTERESTING HE'S IN TROUBLE
FOR EVERYTHING ABOUT MONEY.
NOTHING ABOUT WHAT I FEEL HE
ACTUALLY DID.
DOES ANYONE HAVE COMPASSION FOR
A SEX OFFENDER BEING EXTORTED?
I DON'T.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR WRESTLING
COACHES.
IT'S LIKE, COME ON WE DON'T HEAR
THE JOKES ALREADY.
>> GETTING A BAD WRAP.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK LIKE ME YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT SAILBOATS.
YOU GET IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK LIKE ME, IN OTHER
WORDS A GIRL.
I FEEL VERY, VERY, VERY STRONGLY
THERE SHOULD BE NO TOLERANCE,
ZERO TOLERANCE ALL THE WAY FOR
ANY KIND OF SEXUAL OFFENSE AND
TOWARDS BOYS TOO.
IT'S ZERO TOLERANCE
THERE IS THE IT AND THE POLITICS
ABOUT THE IT.
>> CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR I'M GOING
OUT ON A LIMB WITH YOU AND
AGREE.
>> THANK YOU, JORDAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> TRUTH TO POWER THERE.
>> YES, A RELIEF.
Larry: I DON'T THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A STATUTE OF
LIMITATION ON THESE CRIMES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN A TEACHER
MOLESTS A STUDENT.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH FOR A ADULT TO
DO IT TO A CHILD.
BUT A TEACHER AND A STUDENT.
DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS ?
>> NO.
THERE ARE SERIOUS CRIMES WITHOUT
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
CRIME.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE PRISON
POPULATION.
EVEN WHEN YOU GO TO PRISON A SEX
OFFENDER AND PEDOPHILE KNOW THEY
WON'T HAVE A PEACEFUL TIME IN
PRISON.
IF IT'S BAD AMONG THE WORST OF
THE WORST OFFENDERS THEN --
>> Larry: EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
>> WELL SAID.
Larry: YOU KNOW WHAT GETS ME
TOO IS WHEN GUYS LIKE THIS OVER
DO THE OTHER THING OF
LEGISLATING AGAINST CERTAIN
CRIMES.
SHOULDN'T THAT MAKE US
SUSPICIOUS.
CAN WE BELIEVE ANYONE THAT'S
REALLY VIGILANT ANYMORE?
>> THIS HAPPENS PRACTICALLY
EVERY DAY.
A FANTASTIC AWARD WINNING
JOURNALISM DONE ABOUT GOD'S
HARVEST OR THE PATRICK HENRY
COLLEGE IN VIRGINIA.
IT WAS CREATED SO THAT THE GOOD
CHRISTIAN GOD FEARING CHILDREN
COULD HAVE A GREAT AND SAFE
EDUCATION AND THE GIRLS WOULD BE
SAFE IN A, IN AN ATMOSPHERE OF
COURT SHIP.
>> Larry: I FEEL BAD ABOUT WHERE
YOU'RE GOING.
>> -- A LOT OF ASSAULT AND
LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO, IT JUST GOES TO SHOW THAT
THIS KIND OF HYPOCRISY IS
RAMPANT AND LITTLE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Larry: IT SEEMS LIKE A SHIELD
PEOPLE HAVE TO HIDE BEHIND
THIS ADVOCACY TO GET AWAY WITH
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> YES TAKE THE HEAT OFF.
Larry: LIKE ME I RAIL AGAINST
PIE EATING.
THEN THIS PICTURE.
>> OH MY GOD, LARRY .
>> I CAN'T DO IT.
ALL I DO IS TALKING  ABOUT PIES
MAKING US FAT.
PIES  ARE MAKING US FAT.
WHAT AM I DOING?
>> PIE IN YOUR FACE.
Larry: I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION ABOUT ISIS WE HAVE A
LOT OF ISIS RECRUITING GOING ON.
I CAN' T UNDERSTAND
WHY WOULD AMERICAN YOUTH WANT TO
JOIN ISIS.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND.
THIS AUDIENCE AND THOSE HERE
WOULD UNDERSTAND POWER OF
INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> Larry: SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> YES, GROOMING ON-LINE.
Larry: REALLY?
>> YES INDEEDY.
THEY HAVE 24/7 BANKS OF
RECRUITERS WHO SIT WITH THEIR
COMPUTERS IN TURKEY OR SYRIA
WHERE EVERYONE THEY ARE FINDING
PEOPLE AND GROOMING THEM
ON-LINE.
GROOMING HAPPENS EVERYWHERE.
>> Larry: HIGH-TECH TERRORISM.
>> IT IS. THEY'RE USING OUR
>> INVENTIONS AND TECHNOLOGY AND
DEMOCRACY AND
LANGUAGE AND FILM TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY'RE VERY CLEVER.
>> THEY USE TECHNOLOGY BUT THE
BASELINE APPEAL IS LIFE IS
COMPLICATED.
THERE IS A CAPITOL R ROMANTIC
QUALITY.
>> Larry: LIFE IS COMPLICATED.
JOIN ISIS?
>> YES.
Larry: REALLY.
>> THERE IS A PLACE I HAVE A
ROLE, I KNOW WHERE TO LIVE AND
WHAT TO DO.
IT'S LIKE I NEED TO GET OUT OF
HERE.
LIKE AN EARLY SPRINGSTEEN
QUALITY
LIKE IT'S A TOWN FOR LOSERS.
I'M GETTING OUT OF HERE TO WIN.
TO MAKE MY LIFE MEAN SOMETHING
>> TERRORISTS IN THE USA.
>> IMAGINE THAT.
THEN THESE GIRLS BEING
RECRUITED.
ALL THESE GIRLS BEING
>> Larry: DO THEY UNDERSTAND.
>> THEY DON'T.
THEY ARE GOING OFF INTO A LIFE
OF SERVITUDE OF SLAVERY AND
SEX SLAVERY.
THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING OUT TO
BE WIVES OF JIHADIS AND
UPHOLDERS OF THE ISLAMIC
TRADITION THIS.
IS ALL ABOUT THE EXTREME HARD
LINE WORST OF THE WORST EXTREME
PART OF WHAT IS A VERY, YOU
KNOW DECENT RELIGION
>> Larry: YES.
>> ON TWITTER HOW IS THERE EMOJI
GAME.
>> Larry: EMOJI GAME?
>> YEAH, WHAT ARE THEY USING ?
THE DANCING LADY.
>> BIG SMILEYS AND MAYBE KNIVES.
I SAY THAT WITHOUT BEING FUNNY
EITHER.
THEY ARE.
I HAVE TALKED TO PEOPLE HELD BY
THESE PEOPLE.
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE BEEN HELD
FOR MANY MONTHS INCLUDING BY
THIS GUY JIHAD JOHN.
THE ONE ACCUSED OF SLITTING THE
THROAT OF OUR FRIENDS IN THE
DESSERT FOR THE WHOLE WORLD TO
SEE.
HE SAID TO ME THIS COLLEAGUE
PRESUMABLY THEY PAID A RANSOM
AND GOT OUT.
HE SAID THE FOREIGNERS ARE EVEN
WORST THAN THE LOCALS.
THEY COME TO SHOW THAT THEY'RE
MORE ISIS THAN ISIS.
SOME ARE PSYCHOTIC.
SOME ARE JUST VERY VIOLENT.
THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING OUT FOR
AN ADVENTURE.
IT'S A BLOOD LUST AND A CULT.
>> I FIND IT'S LIKE -- A LOT
LIKE WHITE PEOPLE TRYING TO ACT
BLACK.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: THEY ALWAYS KEEP
IT REAL A LITTLE
EXTRA HARD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.